Tim white student at FES and
coincidentally also former local
official official who got to serve with
my friend here Marty Coburn and a town
nearby with regard to my question is
with regard to the thousands of
jurisdictions in the country many of
which are overlapping state county local
perhaps you have water authorities that
inner and intertwine with all of them
generally do they have do you know if
these jurisdictions have the authority
to create performance measures at this
time I yes they do what I've learned
today and I think we've all been hearing
this for a long time is it we lack a lot
of knowledge that we need to be able to
do that and if you talk about if you go
back to what John said if we it is the
regulatory by by the way just in defense
of lawyers I spy I spend a lot of time
with lawyers who thought that that
defense of the of the patents and the
defense of the compounds was the
silliest thing that ever heard so it's
not I mean obviously those lawyers are
getting paid by their clients to argue a
point of view and they did that very
very effectively from their clients
perspective but we're struggling as
attorneys and we're struggling is the
the regulatory state to figure out what
the majors are I mean listen to the
presentations that you heard this
afternoon the complicated science that's
going into trying to figure out what the
relationships are between fracking and
compounds in the water he's very very
complicated stuff so Intel and that's
one of the interesting things about
adopting best practices into law and
doing measurements and then continuing
to try to do better because it sort of
allows you to
function in the absence of certainty of
regular tainty so the real question you
ask is whether or not local governments
have the authority to adopt
performance-based standards as a
regulatory regime the answer that in
most states is yes then the question
becomes how do they do it I think John's
comment is right on point about how that
have to get started doing that I would
just add a footnote to that which is
some of you may be familiar with the
report from the international energy
agency released last year called golden
rules for Golden Age of gas then he
talked about the need for increased
transparency they knock talked about the
need for companies to earn and maintain
their social licence to operate and they
went through an exercise bunch of
economists went to an exercise of well
what's it going to cost if if companies
adopt best management practices and of
course you know these numbers are sort
of loosey-goosey but I mean what it was
on the order of maybe seven percent or
eight percent in terms of increased
costs so you know there's there's
something to be said for know who goes
naked without auto insurance who goes
naked without homeowners insurance seven
or eight percent not bad to maintain
your social licence operating